how to solve the pursuit so we're deep
diving now I'm going back to X here
rather than Y because we're now doing it
for its own sake rather than as part of
the general cubic all right and just a
historical note like I said the
sixteenth century Italians only used
positive numbers and so they wrote it
like this and they didn't solve only
that they had to solve a bevy of
equations so if we do X X cube plus ax
equals B they'd sent they then C will
execute equals ax plus B is a different
kind of a question and X cubed minus ax
equals B is a different kind of a
question right not to us of course
thank goodness for complex in the part
for our negative numbers but to them
they would say different equation then
that has this solution okay
for us I don't think there's anything
obvious you can do to this to make it
solvable
so let's do that we used to have one
problem now we've got two so we let X
equal year plus P we do the substitution
we expand it there's a cubic part
there's a linear part there's a big bit
of grouping so the factorizing there and
then we can see there's a common factor
here that can okay and I've bolded and
colored that to suggest that this is
somehow progress this this is apparently
going in the right direction all right
is there anything obvious you can do
that now thinking creatively can you
think of anything you could do to that
to make progress to solve it and I'm
sure I wouldn't have thought of anything
sorry factorizing the cubes
I can't you try that thought I'm work
you are right of course because you will
get that factor and so then yep okay
anything else this is actually very much
thinking outside this way yeah having
tension and I hate unintentional puns
I'd rather afford it okay so this can be
solved if then I'm not saying if and
only if I'm saying if
what if three uv+ a were equal to zero
now that doesn't solve it but what if
this term were equal to zero what would
that then imply that's right okay so
working in Reverse if those two things
were true then that would be salt full
enough yep and so this is how we proceed
we derive these simultaneous equations
from them and I said if not if and only
if okay I I when I first read this and
tried doing the work I was thinking okay
driver elegant I like your choice well
duh but what other options are there to
solve this and would they give different
solutions and how do we know this is
heading in the right direction but that
will solve it and so we can make Viva
subject there so the equals negative a
over three you we can substitute it into
there because they both have to be true
and arrive at this so u cube plus how
about you for the cubed equals green
expand that power and we get that now
I'll take that over that any day right
so it was progress and this is a much
easier question what can we do with this
yep Oh before we it's good to get our
bearings here not too many numbers here
that hang our hat on so a and B once the
constants from the equation U and V are
variables because X was equal to new
CrossFit alright so we want to
acknowledge this for you or V or there's
no V so we want to solve it for you we
don't want to solve it for a or b so
solving it for you well let's get rid of
that fraction and we can make the
quadratic okay so if we multiply by the
denominator we get this this is a
quadratic equation in U cubed and
quadratic equations can be solved one
thing I didn't I'll keep that for the
history later now I will mention it now
in sixteenth-century is a leaf the full
thorough treatment about of quadratic
equations have been known for 500 years
450 s and the idea of cubic equations
have been known for a couple of thousand
years you know anything to do with
volume you can make a cubic equation so
and and the the solution that quadratic
equations have been boiling for a long
time
so then people started working on Cuba's
and were quite frustrated that they
weren't getting anywhere so early 16th
century this was a massive breakthrough
and using knowledge that had been around
for you know nearly 500 years okay so
our coefficients are 1 negative B and
that usually we summed them into a
quadratic formula
simplify I'll just go through it sort of
slowly if you want to quickly check that
things are working
get rid of that big fraction
but the half inside the square root and
expand and that's where we leave it for
you cubes right so we've got you cubed
equals half the author - that and we saw
that expression somewhere in one of the
summaries before so two solutions this
often happens doesn't it we derived a
quadratic equation we solve it we have
two solutions and we go alright what are
we going to choose any thoughts
two solutions we need one for you and
one for Vida all right we've been
working with you but X equals u plus V
we need something for you and something
for B so it'd be kind of nice if we
could just say let the positive one vu
and let the negative one BB yeah now in
the article would we derive it by saying
well the relationship between U and V is
U cubed plus b cubed equals B so we can
substitute this in and work it out for V
and yes we do end up with those but for
this presentation I just want to point
out well this is where I come from X
cubed equals ax plus B X equals u plus V
cubed plus b cubed equals b bit of
helpful following so if we allowed you
to than B cube to be the positive and
negative case would that work with that
thing satisfied that must that does
equal B doesn't mm okay so once again
it's an if not an if and only if if we
look at it this way but I like it works
for me
okay so X cubed plus ax plus B has the
solution x equals u plus V where u
equals the cube root of what we just had
it be the cube root of what we just had
and therefore that okay there we go
it started probably Kazumi pretty eh
someone got three UV plus a equals zero
okay now you wouldn't want to write them
too many times so we can summarize it
right we're more interested in the
structure than the nitty-gritty details
so that's a much better and even that
feels frustrating that you can't boil
that down even further because it's so
much similarity there okay so here you
got some conjugate pairs there and we
get a solution to cubic equation or
they'd like to see if you worked with
different combinations of cube roots
then you probably get the other ones as
well
historical though they're only
interested in in positive solutions they
if something seem to be negative they
would have disregarded it as useless not
something we acknowledge and so they
were most in you know they knew that
every cubic equation would have one real
solution and now only interesting ones
have had a positive solution they're
only interested in one solution they
weren't thinking you know maybe we could
generate some more so that's our
solution to the depressed cubic